bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa vj mi stava
stuprando il cavo di merda che prima o
poi lo taglio vi giuro a costo di non
sentire un cazzo era ormai da secoli che
non facevo è più i ragazzi perché
ultimamente sta diventando lentissimo
non carica una mazza quindi spero che il
video di oggi è stata chiesta esca
abbastanza lungo cioè nel senso che ci
siano abbastanza livelli perché non
carica una mazza però ci prova lo stesso
mai così longest botto run ragazzi che
dovrebbe essere il botto ram più lungo
di è previsto non ne sono sicuro ma ci
proviamo lo stesso io per sicurezza ci
manderei avanti lui giusta ok perfetto
fossero lanciato malissimo però in
compenso presso il biberon ma questa
birra ma chi se ne fotte tra winki pro
in kit c'è devo lanciare i bambini no
questo lo devo fare assolutamente se
devo lanciare luke sono il primo a farlo
almeno spero sia questo l'obiettivo si
infatti ragazzi devo purtroppo provarci
perché una figata assurda bimbo lì
allora il primo se stiamo riuscendo a
mancare il cannone cioè la cosa
impressionante è mi è tornato indietro
cioè al riciclo allora ho capito che non
sai contare fino a 4 e difficile lo
capisco ma mio zio mettici di impegno
come il fatto manca nel canone me lo
spieghi
me lo spieghi tu maledizione ragazzi non
sto riuscendo a fare un cazzo
che cosa ve le faccio di una gamba di
merda allora luke devi raggiungere un
[ __ ] 5 pensi di potercela fare
mi è partito un braccio come cazzo mi è
partito un braccio si si le gambe grazie
a dio le gambe sono più intelligenti di
voi
tom houseworth cos'è sta roba come cazzo
fatto a vincere non si aspettava questo
lo devo rifare cioè non ho capito no
mancato la spada nonno di merda non è il
bene bastardo allora devo riuscirci un
secondo
allora che cazzo se stavolta se l'ho
fatto è partita una gamba ma chi se ne
fotte epico suo livello mi gasa troppo
cileno notch al museo nel gene sano come
si deve ragazzi questo è veramente epico
su borgo graham page non so che cosa ma
mi piaceva un casino il titolo buy con
eddy che ancora oggi non abbiamo usato
dobbiamo usare anche ed attento fuoco
d'artiglieria
ok non immaginavo così può che
l'artiglieria ma è così bravo da
riuscire a cos'è perché una bella si è
attaccato al mio culo eh vabbè
riproviamoci un attimo perché se non ci
riuscirò mai non lo sai che se vai così
edy by così mi sembra una no ho vomitato
un braccio cazzo me lo porto come
souvenir perché me lo ricordo sempre sto
momento non so se mi ricapiterà majdic
cosa fanno non sa face qui si provvista
superman non musac
[Musica]
no
la via sven share di due non so che
cos'è la lupi adventure ma da destino
cos'è sta roba
ragazzi io non è da lì che sia sto tizio
ma elsa gelata mente carino quindi che
corini e coccolosi tutti quanti sono
tutti così carine con collegi che mi
viene da essere così tenero allora
abbraccio di gruppo ragazzi ed è bene
così sono molto ma molto amichevole
quando guidò una sottospecie di kirby un
fatto a sfera ragazzi non ha senso suo
livello però mi piace un casino demolire
le cose quindi uno spit si demoliamo
agl'inizi certo le angurie ragazzi già
qualcuno quando una spremuta di angurie
non importa che più grosso ma chi ce
l'ha più grosso ragazzi miei c'è quindi
non pensare che una roccia più grande
possa impedirmi di passare avanti laga
mi sento un demolitore nato perché
quella è quadrato da me ne frega niente
sono arrivato al traguardo è solo il
demolitore il numero uno al mondo ma
anche più coccoloso ragazzi che o
scrivere un pezzo che non facciano
impostino pro vedere se riesco a
riuscirci al primo tentativo anche se
non lo so io comunque allora steve se
non ti ricordi come si gioca me lo dici
favino mi ricordo come si gioca
devi arrivare l'altra parte non solo il
poco ma anche tuo possibilmente quindi
evita di lasciare il poco come un
decerebrato e vedi di saltare come si
deve
mi stanno stuprando in tutti i punti
possibili immaginabili ma scusatemi
ragazze semplicemente steve che non si
ricorda come si gioca
ma come vedete si è ricordato subito in
sei nasa in un deve essere un qualcosa
tipo horror cos'è sta roba ragazzi e
tipo outlast su happy meals in poche
parole cos'è quel nonno ciak
you will find you e grazie mille nonno
non potevi anche non
tranquillo ok ma sotto sequesto una
macchina stupratrice aspetta seconda
scelta
l'inter e vizio bravo così allora adesso
la parola saltarlo però noi di non
affrontarlo così a mani nude
devi saltarlo come fanno i veri uomini
così brava non e non c'è neanche più di
si ed in groppa lo come se fai vedere
che l'uomo fi vedercelo ragazzo scuse
ragazzi è un'orgia di gruppo qualcuno
vuole partecipare salva il ds scuse è
quello sopravvivere agli attacchi su
permessi che non stai così qualcuno
interessato una gamba no ragazzi alla
l'aspettate fatemi capire un secondo
devo scrivere superman un missile nello
stomaco
va bene perché mi lanciano i folletti
addosso ragazzi perché york perché dammi
una risposta tu chi è che in cui la i
folletti da dietro ragazzi potrebbe
avere un senso livello dico potrebbe
perché non so se riesco a trovarci vabbè
l'importante è che schifo i colletti
psichica tasche gli offrì che cazzo fai
sei c'è mio dio non starmi attaccato che
ho 70 al colo york perché vedi che porti
sfiga maledizione no non sono sono
ancora vivo
levati da dio dell'età anno maledetto
bimbo rimane attaccato c'è quando quando
si cerca un bambino sta attaccato alcuno
del padre
dio mio santo comprendiamo così alla
legge ma adesso va beh
l'importante è che abbiamo vinto non ho
trovato il senso visto livello ma
sinceramente non ce lo voglio trovare
100 per cento imporsi con 100 livello e
giudicato impossibile da portare a
termine cioè loro mi dispiace che non
sono sono fatti i geni mi piace proprio
ma devo a votarli dimostrazione che non
è così almeno le gambe cazzo
cosa fai look non ti puoi dondolare
sull'altalena adesso non è il tuo
momento
l'anci yourself devo lanciarmi da solo
andiamo con l'obeso al suo punto perché
è l'unico che ok per evitare di
sfasciare tutto livello forse era meglio
che sollievo lei il padre di john lee
hooker eni.mi fiero le lendini chi è
bravo luke bravissimo ti vedo ci vedo
carico e devo riuscire a praticamente a
toccare il traguardo gli chi cazzo che
non riesco a vincere cioè rendetevi
conto che non riesco a toccare il
traguardo perché c'è gli occhi di mezzo
ragazzi scusatemi se nello scorso
episodio non c'è stato lo scorso
episodio perché ho saltato la domenica
ma mi scuso per appunto averla saltata
quindi devo recuperare è quello di
livelli delicate a me che non ho fatto
ragazzi scusatemi per quelli che li
avevano fatti ci prova allora 99 per
cento imposti vabbè questo ragazzi è
normale ciao pamy sono un tuo
grandissimo farlo quindi conosco
grazie per avermi dato il tempo di
leggere mai steve ci puoi fare guai così
all'inizio con viti al muro sono stati
cosa fa cosa cazzo fa ragazzi che cazzo
chi non se lo accetto ragazzi come cazzo
fatto a vincere
no questo non l'ho capito a novi giuro
questa ha bisogno di un replay perché vi
giuro che non l'ho capita
ma che cazzo succede allora mi ha
sbattuto al muro ho fatto un fatto li
può stimolare il contrario come cazzo
va bè ragazzi si vede che si è talmente
messo a ridere
il gioco in generale che mi ha dato la
vittoria buona
ragazzi io non ho capito che cosa è
successo ma un altro impossible lo devo
fare per questa cosa non l'ho capita ciò
fa dj se non togliere ne fanno la
sbrigati se non succede una brutta cosa
grazie l'avvertimento c'è posso anche
vincere facendo così
[Musica]
ragazzi è sempre più difficile riuscire
a comprendere i vostri livelli
voglio che lo sappiate perché vigiola
ultimamente sto di testa comunque vabbè
andiamo avanti ragazzi faccio l'ultimo
perché non è proprio così
cioè è un olio cram deve riuscire
aprirlo ragazzi faccio questo qua come
ultimo perché gli altri livelli non ce
ne sono
chi cazzo mi dà soddisfazione anche tu
ogni tanto eh vabbè comunque ragazzi
bruno che l'episodio ragazzi anche se è
un po più corto rispetto al solito è
primis mi va di una lentezza o
spropositata oggi comunque ragazzi che
ho chiuso al pil episodio 6 video è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato un
commento vi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come ogni video trovate una
descrizione sempre per iscritti
iscrivetevi noi ci rivediamo il prossimo
vito bei ragazzi